welcome we're going to talk a little bit
about obesity in the child welfare
system and I'm going to go over fairly
quickly five studies that I've already
done in this in this topic and give you
a little background about where I'm
coming from and where I'm hopefully
going with my research so many of you
might not know that obesity in childhood
is measured differently than when you go
to the doctor it's a percentile based on
CDC norms and greater or equal to 95th
percentile for children is considered
obesity and between 85 and 95 is
overweight percentile and we also often
look at high BMI or overweight obesity
anything greater than eighty five
percent weight problems in the child
welfare system in the 1990s underweight
was one of the big problems we used to
think of kids going into child welfare
or being maltreated as being underweight
failure to thrive and obviously that's
not the case things have changed with
that population just has changed with
everybody in the United States so there
have been a few studies looking at the
prevalence obesity steel and Boo she did
a study in Utah kids entering foster
care and the number one medical
diagnosis was overweight and obesity of
children in entering foster care in Utah
I did a study in LA of young children
between H 0 to 5 and i found that
thirteen percent hat were obese and the
percent of in that that's two to five
year olds the 0 to 2 year olds or a
birth to two years old we're not
overweight and obese not greater than
the in haines which is the national
nutrition survey it's the national
survey that give in the united states
how many
kids are overweight and obese the
percent of obese to 25 year olds was
higher than n Haynes but similar to
low-income prevalence of kids that are
low-income and this is a pride primarily
Hispanic population so I also looked at
the in haines for Hispanic kids and the
percentiles stayed the same in the the N
scale which the National Survey of Child
and Adolescent well-being which is a
survey of children who have been
reported for maltreatment in the United
States there have been two em scoffs
studies the second one started about
maybe five years ago or so and in that
one they got Heights and weights but it
was caregiver report so the parents
reported that which is obviously not as
good as when you actually measure
heightened weights and Jesse Hilton from
Illinois looked at ensco the M did
weight for age and i can give you these
slides so you don't actually have to
take any notes if you don't want to if
you would like to you can because you
have a napkin and i thought i'll just
email you the slides so that will make
it easier for you and you won't have to
take notes and you can listen and just
ask questions which I prefer so in in n
ska he did weight for age which is not
quite a very a very reliable or valid
way of doing obesity but it's all he had
and he found that the obesity prevalence
for kids reported for maltreatment ages
2 to 18 was twenty five point four
percent and it was higher among boys and
girls so that's some of the those are
some local statewide and national
statistics on obesity in the child
welfare system the other kind of
research that's been done about obesity
has been done about maltreatment and
much of the research on maltreatment is
retrospective they asked obese adults or
adults in general you know have you been
maltreated you know have you ever been
sexually assaulted those kinds of things
much less research has been done where
they're looking at kids at the time
cross-sectionally and looking at obesity
and maltreatment so a retrospective
studies have found most of them that
adult obesity is linked to childhood
maltreatment and Denise and tan just
published a research article that was a
meta-analysis of 41 studies most of them
retrospective and only none of them with
children as subjects and he found that
maltreatment was related to obesity over
the likes course when you're an adult
but not necessarily for children okay
and that's controlling for other things
like depression anxiety and those things
there have been two prospective studies
using child well well first
substantiated records of maltreatment
one is was done in the Midwest by Kathy
Windham and she found that physical
abuse was associated with high BMI and
adulthood but sexual abuse and neglect
was not were not predictors of high BMI
now that's contrary to a lot of other
research which has shown that sexual
abuse specifically highly related in
women is related to obesity and you
probably have heard of some of that
research or maybe not and my colleague
at USC penny trickett has a longitudinal
study of maltreated adolescence and she
found oh she does in LA but this
research that I'm quoting right now was
done in Washington DC she has a
longitudinal analysis of sexually abused
girls and looked at them be compared to
comparison girls in the same community
and the sexually abused girls had a
higher BMI amor
obesity in adulthood but not necessarily
in childhood the other issue about
obesity is the recent emphasis on the
idea of stress being associated with
obesity I don't know if you've heard the
topic of toxic stress and maltreatment
but it is the type of stress that kids
can't handle basically and adversity
experienced during youth for example
maltreatment but other kinds of
adversity such as having a drug addicted
parent having an incarcerated parent
poverty those kinds of adversity result
in frequent and prolonged activation of
the stress response and it's often
measured using cortisol measures and
it's a problem regular regulating your
response to stress and the Aces study
which was a study done at Kaiser
Permanente in San Diego of middle class
adults a very large population-based
study and you probably there's probably
about 80 articles written on the Aces
study so you may find them in your
reading by Follette II found that
adversity during childhood was related
to all kinds of bad results including
increased incidence of health related
risk behaviors such as drug use you know
those those kinds of things risky sexual
behavior that kind of thing as well as
very poor health outcomes such as early
morbidity morbidity and mortality
cardiovascular disease and obesity and
those studies are have been published in
medical journals and that that was kind
of the beginning of talking about stress
and obesity but what is known about
maltreated children and obesity
and what is unknown what we don't know
really whether the prevalence whether
the prevalence of high BMI ax is similar
for comparable children in the same
community and whether specific types of
maltreatment are related to high BMI and
how removal from the home and put
placement in foster care effects wait so
these are some of the questions that
have furthered my research in this area
and I use two data sets for this
research that I'm going to talk about
and I'm going to try to go over it
fairly quickly so you get this the gist
of the results but I have all but one of
these studies is published so i can give
you the citation for the publication
which might be helpful I looked at penny
trick its longitudinal study of young
young maltreated adolescence and I
looked at it cross-sectionally at the
beginning and longitudinally and I also
looked at a medical clinic in los
angeles in los angeles I don't know if
you're aware we have the largest number
of children and the child welfare system
and the United States it is the only
state that's bigger than LA County in
terms of the size of the child welfare
system is Illinois so we really have a
very big population and in LA we have
clinics that serve just kids going into
child welfare that do their initial
physical exams and I've been doing
research at one of those clinics which
is located at USC yes yes we do the same
thing the kids in foster care so again
so the kids in foster care and kind of
yes we also have that emphasis of
reunited kids with their parents and
keeping them family maintenance as
opposed to putting them in foster care
it's kind of a nationwide thing but
thank you but we are I'm counting not
just kids in foster care but kids who
have who remain at home with their
parents but are receiving services which
I'm sure in New York that's the case too
right yeah so but all these kids if they
receive services from the child welfare
system have to have initial physical
exam within the first 30 days as
recommended by the american academy of
pediatrics and the child welfare league
of america so they all go to a clinic a
special clinic for kids that just serve
kids in the child welfare system and
I've done three studies from that clinic
using their medical records some thank
yous you always have to thank yous to my
co-authors on these studies as well as
my funding sources including the NIH so
the first study i did was looked at the
young adolescents in penny Trickett's
data and i looked at the rates of
obesity in both the maltreated
adolescence and the comparison and one
of the things that she did is that she
has have comparison adolescents in the
same not just census tracks but blocks
within so they have the same
socioeconomic status they're very
similar in ethnicity and age in an
income education all those kinds of
things and I also determined again
looking at whether maltreatment made a
difference in terms of the type of
whether they were obese or not and this
is published in child abuse and neglect
so I used wave one which was collected
between 2002 and
2005 and there were 303 maltreated kids
aged 9 to 12 and 151 who were non
maltreated or comparison youth and these
variables for both the app studies are
the variables I used which include age
gender race ethnicity pubertal stage
using Tanner criteria depression anxiety
and the type of maltreatment one of the
things that penny trickett also did was
she looked at not just the type of
maltreatment that they came in to the
child well first you know the where the
referral was but they looked at four
years previous the case records so all
the different kinds of times they were
reported to jail welfare and the types
of maltreatment and on average kids had
3.7 reports prior to the one they came
into the study with so one had 17
reports prior to this report that they
seventy-six percent of them had multiple
types or poly victimization of
maltreatment and these were the
percentages there were a few kids for
kids who were in the study but were
really at risk for maltreatment because
sibling had been maltreated so they're
not included in this list and I use
logistic regression and to look at BMI
while controlling for those demographic
and psychological covariance obesity
percentages between the maltreated and
the non maltreated 9 to 12 year olds
were the same and they were 27.1 and
34.4 percent were obese and that's
greater or equal to 95 5 percentile
there were actually a higher percentage
in the comparison group than the
maltreated group that had be I am I
over eighty-five percent so they had
high BMI they either had were overweight
or obese and the comparison adolescents
were actually 1.7 times more likely to
have BMI over 85 percentile and there
was a no jetan it was no gender
interaction i looked at maltreatment in
this group whether you were sexually
abused versus the kids who were not
sexually abused so even though i'm
looking at sexual abuse they likely had
other kinds of co other kinds of
maltreatment also and i found that for
overweight obesity females being
physically abused reduced the odds when
you look at stress and maltreatment one
usually thinks that or has found that
sexual abuse is the most stressful for
kids followed by physical abuse
emotional abuse and then neglect not
that they are all not stressful for kids
but in terms of cortisol reactivity and
other stressful measures those that's
kind of how they they are so this was
against my hypotheses this finding and
then for females being physically abused
reduced the odds of being obese just
like overweight for females being
sexually abused reduce the odds of being
obese and for neglect reduce the odds of
a being obese so all these findings were
against my hypotheses but you know that
that's you know that's one of the
reasons i think that the meta-analysis
found that obesity was not specifically
related to maltreatment but even though
that's the case these kids were very
obese and they were more obese than the
in haines national statistics but
similar to others
statistics that we have in LA for
schools in terms of the obesity obesity
epidemic specifically in the area in
which they lived which was kind of a
south central of the eastern part of LA
it was also a primarily Hispanic sample
about sixty percent of them were
hispanic and eighty-eight percent were
african-american or hispanic that's kind
of what this says any questions let me
show you the next study the longitudinal
study which is under review hasn't been
published yet but the gender
relationship to obesity in adults is
different it was different than what I
found and it may be that maltreatment
takes a while to cause the obesity it's
in itself the longitudinal study we used
we looked at the BMI trajectory from age
92 22 so that and we did it by age as
opposed to buy individual so that we
looked at everybody who was 9 years old
everybody who was 10 11 going up to age
22 and we looked at the same four types
of abuse and neglect and we looked at
them compared to other types of
maltreatment as well as the comparison
group I did separate the maltreatment
group a little differently in this one I
looked at everybody taking that idea of
stress everybody with sexual abuse
versus everybody with without sexual
abuse but then I took those people out
and then looked at what was left
everybody with physical abuse and other
co-occurring types of maltreatment and
then versus everybody left and same
thing for for emotional abuse and the
same thing for neglect
and this made four separate groups where
there was no overlapping of groups and I
used individual growth curve modeling
and quadratic and linear and I
controlled for the same demographic
variables and anxiety depression and
pubertal stage this is what for this is
women or girls the boys there were no
differences between between different
types of maltreatment or between the
comparison and the non comparison in the
community but in girls generally most
curves kind of at age about between 15
and 16 17 18 kind of went down and there
were no differences between the total
maltreated and the comparison but there
was a difference between sexual abuse
girls and non sexually abused girls who
didn't have any maltreatment so in this
the darker is the sexual abuse and the
comparison is the lighter and you can
see there was a statistically different
curve for them and the sexually abused
girls continue to go up and wait whereas
the comparison girls about age 16 or 17
started to come down which was kind of
what everybody did in the study but the
sexually abused girls so there is some
theory about obesity being protective in
terms of your body image and not having
you know the opposite sex look at you
and that maybe have gone on for this
group there's also a lot of research on
binge eating and obesity and binge
eating is more likely and sexually
abused girls since then sexually abused
boys and binge eating also not only
causes obesity it
perpetuates obesity so that may be
another possible explanation for this
but this kind of reinforces penny
Trickett's research she did just on
sexual abuse because we did not find any
differences in the non sexually abused
girls um so we just said that so these
studies are in a very dense urban sample
I wasn't able to control for all the
things you really want to control for an
obesity research which is parental
weight status because many of these kids
are in foster care and then we're not
with their parents and we did not have
their parents weights and I used
official child welfare records and you
know which may be different if you ask
people if they've been maltreated so we
talked a little bit about the catch
clinic which is a community assessment
and treatment clinic in Los Angeles and
it's in right next to the County
Hospital in Los Angeles it's one of the
seven hubs only takes kids who are in
the child welfare system and I they are
seen up where's about a thousand kids a
year so I was able to look at a lot of
medical records with very valid and
reliable heights and weights and I
looked at birth date gender ethnicity
exam date recorded weights and the
maltreatment type that came from DCFS
when they were referred to the clinic so
not looking at their previous records
just what came so again I've tried to
see for this a very large sample whether
there was any relationship between the
maltreatment type and obesity and this
is published in child maltreatment I
looked at poly victimization which means
more
and one type of melt maltreatment as
opposed to only one type and I looked at
abuse versus neck of neglect anybody who
did was only neglected versus only
abused either sexually physically or
emotionally abused this is was a study
of 2,000 subjects 2 to 18 year old years
old who attended their initial foster
care clinic medical appointment at catch
so these were all in foster care and for
this study there were no kids with their
birth parents they were not pregnant and
they were all Hispanic there were about
twenty percent who are not Hispanic but
this made it we I used a within group
study just looking at Hispanics and I
could compare it to the national
statistics for Hispanics I also use
logistic regression and I separated boys
from girls and the overweight obesity
percentage here see if I can hard to see
that the very right top for for these
hispanic 22 18 year olds was thirty nine
point five percent overall but for the
12 to 18 year olds that was forty seven
point seven percent were at a high
weight almost half of them or either
overweight or obese there was no
difference by gender and very few of
them were underweight much fewer than
the national estimates for kids
nationally or underweight which is close
to three percent three to four percent
and this is was close was two percent so
this is not an underweight population
anymore looking at logistic regression
as you age is more likely for you to be
obese so
you have a 1.67 times greater odds of
being obese at 12 to 18 then to 25 and
this you had greater odds at 12 to 18
then six to 11 for both boys and girls
and the girls are on top and the boys
are they on the bottom and once again my
hypothesis was not confirmed in fact
there was no difference between
maltreatment types in terms of obito
beasts of in terms of neglect versus
abuse and for poly victim victimization
actually decreased the obesity and kids
so nonetheless these kids were more
obese the National Hispanics and we need
to probably look at the community and
family more than maltreatment itself in
terms of looking at what's happening in
the obesity of this population i also
got from the catch clinic a bunch of
kids who were in long-term foster care
is that what it's called in in New York
does anybody know that basically they
had permanency as their plan and and
they were not adoptable and they were
not going to be returned to their
parents so they weren't considered in
long-term foster care as their
permanency plan in Los Angeles County
and this is published in maternal and
child health journal which is a public
health journal and I looked at
overweight and obesity and I looked
whether placement types had anything to
do with their obesity so for for us in
California there are many permanency
options and adoption kinship
guardianship kinship long-term foster
care unrelated guardianship unrelated
long-term foster care in a family home
or long-term foster care and group homes
and long-term foster care nationally is
the least the BET least best of those
options we had 312 kids aged 22 18 and
this was from 2006 to 2010 and this is
the first appointment and catch but it
doesn't necessarily they've obviously
been in foster care for quite a long
time to have being permanency and foster
in long-term foster care because usually
we try to get them adopted where we turn
them home before that happens but I
didn't have their initial weights
and heights when they enter foster care
so I use the analysis of variance
chi-square sweats test and fisher's
exact tests as well as multiple
regression this is these are the
demographics of the kids we had in group
home 40 of them were in groups group
homes 203 word unrelated foster care and
69 were in kinship foster care the the
genders were about the same there were
more older kids than younger kids and no
two to five year olds in group homes and
they were most of them were either black
or Hispanic and there were more
Hispanics in kinship foster care then
the other kinds of placements this is
the same statistics as I found for the
Hispanic study is that almost 40% of
them that were overweight or obese but
sixty percent in group homes were or
overweight or obese so that's more than
half and the greatest percentage in
group homes and there's maybe a lot of
reasons for that it's not necessarily
that the group homes are causing that
and what I'm going to talk a little bit
about that
and as they get older except for the six
to look at this for a second this is the
regression analysis and the only thing I
founded it were 12 to 19 s were years
old were 2.1 times more likely to be
overweight obese than two to five year
olds the rates were higher than the N
Hanes for two thousand to two thousand
seven to two thousand eight for the
twelve to eighteen year olds but that
Anna to 25 year olds but knocked for the
middle group not for the six to 11 year
olds they were less obese than national
studies they had lower prevalence of
obesity and overweight than the end end
sample and the older youth who many of
them were in group homes were you know
in terms of trying to explain why their
obesity level was so high many of them
are often on psychotropic medications
both kids older kids in foster care are
more likely to be on psychotropic
medications and kids in group homes as
opposed to family foster homes or more
likely to be ins on psychotropic
medications and psychotropic medications
are much more related to obesity so that
could be one of the reasons it you know
it's it's odd because in set in group
homes the diets are much more controlled
than in family foster homes so it may be
that there the medications have more to
do it or do with it or they're coming
into group homes more likely to be more
likely obese or overweight so we need
targeted prevention and intervention al
I wrote in this that maybe we should
possibly start with group homes because
the diets are so controlled in many
group homes very large group homes have
actually died dietitians that are on
call so it might be a way of doing
that and the latest law on fossil called
the fostering connections to success and
increasing adoptions act or fostering
connections could act actually addresses
obesity in it in terms of foster care
that we need to do something about
obesity and maybe that will make a
difference and the final study the armor
tell you and you're going to be happy to
know it's the final study is looking at
what happens in foster care over a year
there was have only been one study that
looks at this and that was done in the
UK and I don't know the ethnicity of the
population but they actually increased
the proportion of obesity over a year of
the kids in looked after care which is
what it's called in the UK so i looked
at the prevalence of high weight
categories upon entrance to foster care
and after one year in foster care and i
compared them to national statistics and
I explore the relationships of changes
in weight status to the age the reason
for entry and the placement type and
this is published in child abuse and
neglect I had 360 kids and the UK study
had about a hundred kids aged 0 2 19
they attended their initial appointment
when they entered foster care at the
catch clinic and then 1 10 to 14 months
later and the mean was twelve point
three months they were in foster care
when they attended all their
appointments and this was done between
2006 and 2010 medical records I used
chi-square tests as well as the
MacNamara tests for comparing paired
proportions what happened is when you
look at these you look at it by age
between 0 to 2 2 to 5 6 to 11 and 12 to
18 so when I was looking at proportions
I did it using the MacNamara test for
everybody but many of them
change what age they were in you know
and they ruin a year so they changed
from 0 to 22 to 25 year olds so I looked
at the proportions at those particular
ages and i looked at the change in
weight categories and I categorized them
by looking at either a decrease in
weight which mean they went from obese
to overweight or overweight to normal
weight or I looked at increased they
went the opposite way like normal to
overweight or overweight to obese or
they stayed in their overweight or obese
category or and they remain normal
weight so I mean if you had more kids
you could look at a change in weight
within the normal weight because if you
went you were at thirty percent and the
in a year you were up to seventy percent
that in itself would be a serious
problem but I wasn't able to do it for
this study here are the kids and the
only significant changes in weight were
the two to five year olds they
significantly changed from being obese
or overweight to more likely normal
weight after a year in the total
population there was no difference in
obesity after year for the total
population there was a difference
between overweight and obesity greater
than eighty-five percent for the total
population driven by the two to five
year olds so I found that age predicted
the change in weight category from year
one from time 12 time to under two year
olds they entered foster care they were
normal weight and they stayed normal
weight while they were in foster care
the two to five year olds decrease their
weight
the six to 11 year olds increase their
weight they were more likely to become
from normal to overweight or obese or
from overweight to obese and that 12 19
year olds came in overweight or obese
and stayed that way placement was not
related to weight change and the only
type of reason for foster care that was
related was parental drug use which I
could not really explain why that was so
that's okay we compared these categories
to the national statistics at time one
for obesity kids who were younger than
two had a lower prevalence of obesity 22
19 year olds was higher and overweight
and obesity was higher for the 22 19
year olds but at time to the lower the
under two year olds remained lower fruit
and the two to five year olds became
lower the national statistics and the 69
19 year olds remained higher so just
that to 25 year olds changed and there
were no differences when I looked at
only Hispanics statistics why did these
two to five year olds lose weight in
foster care when nobody else did and it
may not be the foster Keller itself it
could be that there's a lot of research
about two to five year olds they're much
more active they go to preschool many of
them go to preschool it's a time when
generally kids who might have been obese
when they were under two are not obese
when they are starting to be active so I
I don't know whether it was foster care
that did that or it was just the natural
progression of being more active in
their in their lifestyles I did not find
any significant increase in the
prevalence of obesity in foster care nor
did I find other
the 20 to 25 year olds the kids in
foster care actually lost weight so you
know that was that they did find in and
UK they did actually find that they
gained weight so from this study is
where I'm kind of going now it suggests
that we should do something about the
this the kids who are six or older and
who will come into foster care obese but
there were quite a few kids who were not
obese and became obese in foster care
also specifically in the six to eleven
year old group because a change in home
environment may not actually do anything
for their obesity some there are
suggestions that BMI percentiles should
be added to their child welfare
department files and that we need to
train caregivers no beasts the
interventions but when I started
thinking about that I thought we better
look at whether actually what's
happening in the home really is
reflected in the kids behavior whether
what's practice in the home and what the
caregiver is actually doing is actually
what the kids are doing specifically in
foster care and I'm going to talk about
that in a minute but there's a lot of
limitations because i use retrospective
medical records it was a largely
Hispanic population I didn't have child
welfare records to look at all the
different types of maltreatment these
kids were exposed to wheres didn't have
the birth parents BMI or birth weight
data specifically to visit for the 0 to
2 year olds you really need to control
for birth weight just to look at obesity
and I didn't have their placement
history in most studies 0 to 2 years
olds do not use the CDC
sept-iles it's recommended now they use
the World Health Organization norms but
I couldn't do that because many of the 0
to 2 year olds became two to five year
olds during the study so I looked at I
used only the CDC norms for this study
and from LA this is what we know that
maltreated kids have high levels of over
overweight and obesity that now
treatment types are not the driving
force it may be a combination of
environment genetics family that foster
care does not increase obesity and the
child welfare system for me needs to
make prevention and treatment of obesity
a priority there also has been a lot of
controversy I don't know if you've read
about it but it's been in national
newspapers it's been an internet that
there were a couple articles one in JAMA
a journal of american medical
association one in the journal
Pediatrics about thinking about obesity
as a type of medical neglect and putting
kids in foster care as a treatment for
obesity there there there was a
editorial in JAMA because I think
pediatricians are very stumped on what
to do and this they know that these kids
need a change and this is what they can
think that foster care is supposed to
make that change but from my research
foster care does not treat obesity and
putting kids in foster care may also
increase their stress which is highly
related to obesity so there have been a
lot of pushback from the child welfare
professionals and researchers about this
and there are four states that are now
removing kids from them their home for
obesity treatment in foster care and
here are some of the things that
been talking about place you know beasts
children and foster homes a
controversial proposition but it's
actually being done today not everywhere
but in some places although parents are
suing the child welfare system about it
where do we go from here I'd like to
hear your thoughts but one thought that
I have is poor sending a grant in to the
NIH to study this to look prospectively
about what happens to both normal weight
and obese children when they're placed
in the home prospectively looking at
kids I'm going to just look at Hispanic
kids because that's what you know that's
a increasing majority of kids in LA and
in California are Hispanic in foster
care and and in California more we have
more Hispanics than not Hispanics in the
and the state looking at the influence
of caregivers health behaviors their own
dietary intake and their own activity
levels and their home environment such
as TV watching you know access to park
parks and access to after-school
activities those kinds of things on
health behaviors and obesity levels of
children who are evolved in the child
welfare system looking at differences
between children who remain home or
maltreated and children who are in
foster care and also looking at the role
of stress both for the parents or
caregivers and also for the child in
terms of mediating that relationship
between what happens in the home and
what happens at it in the child's life
and I'm going to look specifically at
six to 11 year olds because in my study
those are the kids who gained weight and
I want to see what's happening before we
look at what to do in placing
interventions in foster care homes there
is a lot of literature that says that
home based interventions
are even more successful than school
based or community-wide interventions
for obesity but none of them has been
tested in foster homes so I think we
kind of need to know what's happening in
these homes before we place
interventions that have been not
designed for foster homes in foster
homes are there questions comments I'm
very interested in what you have to say
about what I talked about in your own
experience are any of you working with
kids in foster care or you are do you
find them obese or normal weight you
haven't seen that not particularly yes
yes
there was a study done in Virginia by a
nutrition PhD student who's finished her
program and it's going to be published
in Youth and Family Services review that
looked at the eating and activity levels
in home environment in foster homes in
Virginia and almost eighty percent of
the parents in the foster homes the
foster care givers were obese in
Virginia and the kids were also about
the same in terms of forty to forty
about forty percent overweight and obese
so I mean it's a problem because we you
know in your case the birth parents
enough and how about the foster parents
were not obese and the kids not so okay
Oh babies yeah yeah I think that's like
very small kids I don't know the
necessary underweight but there's one
particular damn thinking he's 16 he's
actually in eighth grade and look at the
same sizes on the sixth graders okay so
there's like kissing both spectrums okay
I'm
I don't know just like the bump
developing later or maybe has some
metabolic problem or you know we don't
know yeah any other questions or
comments you can ask them all primarily
we I didn't have most of the kids that
the parents are often born elsewhere but
the kids are often born in LA and the
longer the parents stay here the more
likely they are going to be take our
lifestyle and be yes they do but these
are these appearance that often have
been here a long time the kids are
usually born here so they take our our
lifestyle behaviors in America and adopt
them as opposed to the lifestyle
behaviors of the grandparents or the
parents so no I
yes so almost all on well usually they
get on lunch at school not always
breakfast yeah but always almost yeah
yeah most of the schools in la provide
lunch and I'm not necessarily breakfast
yeah yeah oh ok they they generally in
LA get lunch and not necessarily
breakfast but it's it they still you
know when they come home one second
always you know it's it's really what's
in the house it's on the weekends it's
you know you think of other ways of
doing things yes yes the dangers like to
get shopping for diamonds that happen
sure and that's a lot of it why the kid
part of you could you know they aren't
being active if they should be good mean
I think that's like an hour a day of
activities at least five days a week
they can cook like the last thing I
heard and so kids needs more done
getting that yes these you're absolutely
right these are low-income neighborhoods
that are violent you know i don't i
don't know whether i can compare the
violence in LA to the violence here in
New York but I mean we have very poor
neighborhoods and LA and many gangs just
as you do so whether the parks are
really available is something I'm going
to look at and it's a very good point so
I'm good when I do this should the NIH
choose to sit to shoot to fund me I'm
going to have
the kids in the same neighborhoods who
remain at home and it remain and who go
into foster care to see if there is a
difference in terms of what foster care
can do for these kids but you're right
you know the recommendations for
exercise sometimes cannot be done
because of where they live absolutely
well they were more obese in group homes
they were sixty percent of them were
overweight or obese but they were at
older population and you know I don't I
didn't have their medication history
which I hopefully will get I didn't have
pubertal status because this was a
retrospective medical record study so i
didn't have pubertal status which is
important to control for so i only had
all he could do the prevalence of
obesity based on age gender ethnicity
and placement so absolutely that maybe
some of the reason that that they were
so overweight and obese in the group
homes
yeah i mean i think that one of the
issues is not the obesity itself which
is you know it's detrimental to their
health but the fact that these kids have
the highest rates of chronic illness in
the united states many of them have
asthma which obesity makes it harder to
treat so it's a combination of all those
things and this is yes there is so in
this hopefully new study I'm going to
control for those kinds of things
because I'll have access to that
information not just psychotropic
medications but it steroids and other
kinds of medications that cause weight
gain I'll have more information about
that pardon me that's ok screen time yes
we have a home environmental measure
that looks at screen time that we're
using or we're planning on using and I
have a pediatric endocrinologist we're
not going to take blood even though they
want me to because it's very traumatic
going to people's homes and bringing it
full botanist take blood but not they
wouldn't invite us back again I don't
think so we're going to look at there is
a way of looking at insulin sensitivity
through darkening in the neck I on we're
going to do that kind of thing so we're
going to estimate insulin sensitivity
and we're going to do body fat
measurements we're there in the home
yeah well I think that this is yeah well
it's also extremely expensive that would
be everything yeah it's racist yes
there's a megrim I forgot the name
account this Negron's and I can email it
to you it's a specific kind of darkening
of the neck that happens when you have
changes with insulin sensitivity and
it's correlated to BMI and I can send
you that information yes type 2 not type
1 no yes and these are the kids that
potentially could get type 2 diabetes
not type 1 not genetic you remind me in
the very first study yes you have
children from the same census tract is
that right same not just only centric
same blocks census blocks yes but the
obesity is not any different it not
different between the two groups which
suggests that the community the
community yes yes and these kids the
maltreated kids only about most of them
we may do it in their home these were
maltreated it was study on maltreatment
not a silly foster care about um maybe
thirty percent of them out treated we're
in foster care most of them were at home
or with relatives it's a community kind
of thing yes that's right the maltreated
group in the yap study physical health
was not any different
we have a paper we're going to publish
about this than the kids in the in the
community the psychological health the
maltreated kids had much higher
depression anxiety and other
psychological measures yes do that child
it'll be in and of itself considered
abuse it's called yes it's a medical
neglect and it's not just obesity its
obesity that's coupled with medical
consequences like type 2 diabetes some
kids get apnea from their of these or
not being able to breathe at night
difficulty sleeping all kinds of other
medical problems as a result of the
severe obesity not just ninety five
percent of above usually more like at
the very top ninety-nine percent so if
they can't the parents can't help the
doctor control the obesity to treat the
other problems the child have they were
taking kids out of their home to put
them in foster care as a type of medical
neglect so but you know obviously the
parents are not happy and are suing
these child welfare systems and the
state's about this but it is happening
in different states you know whether we
don't from this study and from other
studies we don't know that that actually
works to treat obesity by taking them
out of their home
well they're trying it you know they're
trying to improve the health of kids by
removing them from their environment so
is it you know it's by treating the
obesity by decreasing their weight so
basically that's the treatment yes I'm
glad you well if it's funded Yakima
anything yes we're going to do we're
going to do cheek swabs for cortisol
both morning appt you know five quarters
all samples for a day are similar but
it's not it's a it's a drug drug abuse
of the you know whether it's parental
drug abuse or exposure to drugs it's not
that these kids had drug problems it was
their parents drug problem sure yeah
yeah that's possible
increase the poly victimization yes
because poly victimization is often
related to poor educational outcomes
poor everything showing no difference
between I wasn't sure if you're going to
look at sort of the within-group yes i'm
going to i'm actually going to have
seven measures of stress for the kids
besides cortisol depression anxiety
daily stress health other health stress
yeah i'm looking at lots of different
things it's possible I mean I because i
don't have measures of binge eating so i
don't i don't really know but you know
there is some data about binge eating
and you know as being related to
maltreatment specifically sexually a
sexual abuse and also in terms of
specifically for girls and and obesity
but i appreciate your suggestions yeah
it's a it's very complicated so that
just placing these interventions that
are even for low-income families that
are that are in non foster care homes
nom non maltreating homes may not be the
answer unless we know more about what
happen is happening in those
about eating behavior and physical
activity behavior and stress so
hopefully I can find some of that out so
the proposition is to look at these kids
a 450 families kids over a year in
foster care or a year at home and doing
three time points of measurements yes
yeah that you're very right that that
could make a difference but this was a
medical record retrieval so all I had
the only information I had was that they
were in a group home when they came and
that that was their permanency placement
but definitely that could make a very
big difference about what was happening
in the group home in terms of the staff
and the support systems that they had
within that group home or not absolutely
any other questions or comments well I
really appreciate you coming and if you
would like a copy of the this was taped
so you can look at the tape but you
don't have to do that because you've
already been here if you'd like a copy
of the PowerPoint I'd be happy to give
it to you in that way you would have it
and you can look up the articles if
you're interested I have and I can send
you the last article when it gets
published which is the one that shows
sexually abuse females higher BMI growth
over time thank you so much